two-minute warning before the birthdays
begin
[Music]
hello everyone the front page of the New
York Times is not the venue for
discussing classified information the
White House podium is not the venue for
discussing classified information we are
here today having this discussion
because of an irresponsible anonymous
leak to the New York Times there is no
good scenario as a result of this New
York Times report who's going to want to
crawl cooperate with the United States
intelligence community who's going to
want to be a source or an asset if they
know that their identity could be
disclosed which allies will want to
share information with us if they know
that some rogue intelligence officer can
go splash that information on the front
page of a major US newspaper
specifically there are two bad scenarios
that emerge from this report number one
this report makes it more difficult to
come to a consensus on this matter to
verify intelligence and number two this
level of controversy and discord plays
directly into the hands of Russia and
unfortunately serves their interests
since before President Trump assumed
office damaging and oftentimes erroneous
leaks seeking to undermine or D
legitimize the duly elected president
have been published according to the DOJ
classified leaks surged in this
administration there were under
President Obama just 39 on average
criminal leak referrals in this
administration we've seen 100 criminal
leak referrals to the DOJ in 2017 88 in
2018 and 104 on average per year we have
seen targeted leaks of classified
information against this president and
it is irresponsible phone calls with
foreign leaders meetings with government
officials and now reports of alleged
intelligence make no mistake this
damages our ability as a nation to
collect intelligence
as the National Security Council noted
just yesterday to those government
officials who betray the trust of the
people of the United States by leaking
classified information
your actions endanger our national
security the odni said the Selective
leaking of any classified information
disrupts the vital interagency work to
collect assess and mitigate threats and
places our forces at risk
it is also simply put a crime
and finally the CIA said this that leaks
compromise and disrupt the critical
interagency work to collect assess and
ascribe culpability to the anonymous
sources who leaked classified
information you should know this you may
seek to undermine our president but in
fact you undermine our country's safety
and our country's security and with that
I'll take questions Kristen what did
White House officials first learned that
this intelligence about Russian Downey's
existence I will say this the president
was never briefed on this this
intelligence still has not been verified
and there is no consensus among the
intelligence community does the
president wish that he had been briefed
sooner I mean today Joe Biden called it
a dereliction of duty this is a piece of
intelligence information that had no
consensus has not been verified still to
this day has not been verified and there
are several intelligence agencies on the
record noting that you have the
Department of Defense saying that there
has they have no corroborating evidence
to validate validate the recent
allegations then SC allegations and
recent press articles have not been
verified or substantiated by the
intelligence community in the odni we
are still investigating the alleged
intelligence referenced in recent media
reporting's but that didn't stop the New
York Times from putting it on the very
first page of their newspaper and
stopping us from getting to an ultimate
conclusion in an ultimate place of
having a consensus on the alleged
intelligence darling
you see former question if this
intelligence does turn out to be true is
the president prepared to take some
serious action against Russia and
Russian President Vladimir Putin the
president has always taken tough on
adulterated action against Russia we saw
that there's no diplomatic presence on
the west coast of our country of Russia
because the president closed the
consulates we saw he expelled 60 Russian
intelligence officers sanctioned
hundreds of targets withdrew from the
INF treaty the Open Skies treaty tried
to halt nordstrom's still trying to do
that impose visa sanctions and many
other actions so make no mistake this
president is prepared to act and will
always act in protecting our American
troops we saw in Syria and the strikes
in 2018 that dozens of Russian
mercenaries were killed he will always
act protect to protect American troops
that is indeed his track record darling
there's a briefing in everything on the
president's schedule today will this
matter be part of his briefing this
afternoon the president has been briefed
on what is unfortunately in the public
domain because of the New York Times and
the irresponsible leaked yes he has been
briefed but that does not change the
fact that there is no consensus on this
intelligence that still has yet to be
verified yes darling on another subject
[Music]
like Kevin McCarthy and Lamar Alexander
have said that it would be great if the
president would wear a mask in public
sometimes to set an example how much
weight do words from McCarthy as the
president has said he has no problem
with mass that he encourages people to
make whatever decision is best for their
safety and to follow at their local
jurisdiction say CDC guidelines are
still recommended but not required and
the president is the most tested man in
America it's his decision whether to
wear a mask example Justin you saying
that the president never been briefed
there's I think some dispute over
whether in February is PDB included this
intelligence information so I'm
wondering if you can say whether or not
you know he may not have read the
briefing book that he was presented with
but was he at some point at least given
access to this information the PDB is a
top-secret document that is widely
disseminated among government I will
never sit here and confirm or deny what
is in a top seek secret document so I'll
leave it at that one thing I will say
that is routine is when there is
intelligence and I was speaking with um
some folks over in NSC about this
earlier and some other folks around the
White House when we get intelligence
verified or unverified to deem credible
or not credible deemed consensus or no
consensus if that information in any way
impinges upon the safety of our troops
that information goes to our troops on
the ground in to our allies so they can
take the appropriate measures on what is
briefed up to the president in this case
was not the case was never briefed to
the President of the United States
because there was no consensus what is
briefed to the president is when there's
a strategic decision to be made so in
this case if there was a strategic
decision to be made visa V Russia those
are the kind of things that are briefed
to the president when they're deemed
credible but in this case it was not
briefed to the president there's no
consensus it was not credible but make
no mistake this president will always
protect American troops
just the following that I think there's
two points one I would say that press
secretaries in the past have disclosed
in certain instances what was in the PDB
but secondly I mean this is a relevant
issue because I think critics have
already seized on this and said well the
president isn't reading his PDB he might
not know that there are these policy
decisions to be made right if a
president was presented with this
information
it's unverified he could be alarmed
change his posture towards Russia
conceivably asked intelligence officials
to work harder to determine whether or
not this was true make you know series
of judgments and so I guess more broadly
you know I would react the question of
whether it was in his material but
asking maybe to defend why the president
is necessarily reading of PDV when there
are these types of issues that arise the
president does read and he also consumes
intelligence verbally this president
I'll tell you is the most informed
person on planet earth when it comes to
the threats that we face
you have ambassador O'Brien who sees him
in person twice a day who sometimes
takes the upwards of half a dozen calls
with this president he's constantly
being informed and briefed on
intelligence matters but I'm not going
to allow the New York Times to dictate
when we give top-secret information and
don't give top-secret information that's
where the whole proposition there that
yes in role thanks Kaylee did he have
any comment on Bruce or testifying
before the Senate Judiciary Committee on
the hill today so no comment
not specifically but what I would say
more generally is that what Bruce or and
others in the Obama era government have
to answer for is quite substantial
when you had a dossier full of lies
weaponized against this president Bruce
or his wife of course being involved in
the creation of that dossier which was
funded by the Democrat National
Committee and in coordination with the
Hillary Clinton campaign and was used to
spy on the Trump campaign to be the
basis for two FISA warrants to launch a
three year investigation into Russia
collusion that ultimately ended in an
exoneration of this president and
is waste of taxpayer dollars mr. Orr and
many others have a whole lot of
questions to answer for why was it
behind closed doors why wasn't it tell
the buttons given the public interest in
these players in the Russia
investigation now that would be a
question for Congress but I think the
public deserves to know
mr. oars answers on those matters and
one more myth about leaders Democrat
lawmakers are calling for a briefing
from intelligence officials they are
satisfied with the White House personnel
today is there a concern to brief
Democratic lawmakers especially on shift
giving the leaks out of his committee
look I mean I think that Democrats
should come forward in good faith and if
anyone has politicized intelligence
we've had the New York Times acting
entirely or responsibly and you have the
Democrat Party politicizing this
information which i think is absolutely
disgraceful alator
hi yes thank you Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell said today that Russia
should quote absolutely not unquote be
allowed back into the g7 this president
Trump agree with Mitch McConnell look I
haven't spoken to him on that matter the
President believes that we have to have
diplomatic relationships relations with
the top economies of the world but
there's been no one that's been tougher
on Russia than this president I went
through several of those actions and
also I would note that when it comes to
acting on viable actionable credible
intelligence there has been no one who
has acted more forcefully than this
president he has a track record of that
he has made protecting our American
troops overseas his highest and
strongest priority you as you know
Soleimani was responsible for the deaths
of 600 Americans and thousands maimed
from quote explosively formed
penetrators other improvised explosive
devices improvised rocket assisted
munitions rockets mortars
rocket-propelled grenades small arms
snipers and other attacks in Iraq this
is what soleimani
did to our American troops you had
President Bush who declined to strike
Soleimani who was quote in the
crosshairs according to the New York
Times you had Obama Biden who quote
never made an effort to strike soleimani
but you had this president who
he had actionable intelligence to
protect American troops he did it he
took that option he was criticized by
Democrats Democrats condemned Trump's
strike on soleimani
as your publication Axios had in a
headline NBC said Democrats demand
answers on soleimani killing Politico
top Democrats blast Trump's false
justification for soleimani killing in
the Atlanta cast why kill Soleimani now
we removed Soleimani from the
battlefield President Trump did to
protect our American troops based on
credible intelligence he did the same
with al Baghdady who was responsible for
300 public beheadings who killed
thousands of captured prisoners of war
when this president had actionable
intelligence he took action criticized
by Democrats for it but that's what this
president does he acts in defense of our
American troops who's doing the
targeting and why are they doing it it's
a it's a great question but these are
rogue intelligence officers who are
imperiling our troops lives we will not
be able to get very very likely not be
able to get a consensus on this
intelligence because of what was leaked
to the New York Times and you have both
the NSC Odie and I and CIA all noting
what damage this leaks does not just to
the safety of our troops which is
paramount but to the ability of the
United States to aggregate information
from our allies and have assets and hot
get this valuable information so who's
doing it it's members of the IC are
going after Trump is that were you
saying it very possibly could be and if
that's the case it is absolutely
despicable
yes uh no administration doing anything
or taking any action like an audit of
the IC or what steps are you planning on
taking to try to find out source of Li
well make no mistake
the DOJ has done several criminal leak
referrals one under 20 in 2017 88 and
2018 104 on average per year under
President Trump so we do take those
steps and we do have a president who
ultimately when it comes down to the
safety of our troops he doesn't take
impulsive action he takes two liberabit
action and we saw that in the killing of
Soleimani and the killing of al-baghdadi
and the protecting of our troops and at
the same time when you had Iran who shot
down a drone he chose not to strike back
in that instance he chose to protect
civilians to protect our troops it was
the measured response it was
proportionate response and ultimately
the ultimate way to protect American
troops is to not get into needless
foreign wars this president is on record
for decades and decades and decades
opposing opposing foreign wars in Iraq
is a great example a 20 nearly two
decades or you have this president who
when Washington was unanimous and saying
we're going into Iraq this president
said no that's not the right decision
he's wound down our troop presence in
Afghanistan in Iraq and he's ultimately
protected American troops and kept this
country safe and as president president
has a very strong foreign policy record
to be incredibly proud of thank you
you
you
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two